[Música]
[Aplausos]
se mire
[Música]
el pequeño se localicen y esta canción
parece lo que es como una fusión y
quiero que sea británico
así que el vice para de peinado al
permiso para el costado y prepárate ya
falta poco
i
[Música]
algo igual un día se le derramó
además de la máquina
[Música]
de la nada
de la nada yo quiero que esté a mi lado
nada de nada
para las que se colocan los granos
[Música]
no sé qué hacer
en mayo de un día escuchar la radio
no quiero nada
para nada
para ganar
no quiero que tú eres de turista junto a
mí cada naranja
de la planta
de aralar
más
[Música]
ah
apuntalada
caracas
ya verás
para nada
canadá
[Música]
salgan
para aralar a ganar a ganar a nadal a la
sala
llega la hora de la verdad
para nada
[Música]
no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cómo
cuando era pequeñita mi mamá me decía
que la razón era que estaba
y yo que era muy curiosa de pronto me
salí llegando a la calle lo que descubrí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
s
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no no
esto era mi querida casa mamá me decía
que fuera estaba
yo era muy curiosa de pronto me salí ya
llegando a la calle
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hay que empezar culebras y culebras
[Música]
no
guardia
[Música]
r
ribera del ebro
bailan culebrón que reagan gata
hay la culebra la culebrilla se va
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ahora
a la larga dar la cara
para darle lugar a la gala
declarada la largada
para la la la la la la la la
[Música]
aranda
y las hay las hay
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y eso voy a matar me importa
[Música]
tú
no se comía
[Música]
rompe tu estás
me pierdo buscando
compré tú estás
se sabe
no de verdad
seguro bailando y le sigo aquí
verde a esperar
maría deportes desde su bares tanto
maría de informes que yo no tengo tanto
maría ni por qué porque tú vales pues
tomaría deporte
si yo no tengo tantos
[Música]
donde tú estás
así que tiendo a buscarte
donde tú estás que me has hecho saber
venga atrás
seguro hay nada y yo sigo aquí
fuerte esperar
varía deporte porque tú valen tanto
mariani porque si yo no tengo tanto
maria di porque es porque tú vales tanto
maria deportes que yo no tengo tantos
e
[Música]
vuelve a tu vale tanto marear y porque
si yo no tengo tanto maria divertido
porque tú vales tanto maria di porque
ellos no tengo tantos varían y porque
varía de importe varía deporte barrial
y por qué
y yo no tengo nada
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e
eso
hago ver la gorrita amor
ah
a ver
[Música]
a ver a ver a mover las bolitas si no
nadie decente wagon hermanita a ver a
ver a mover la colita si no la puede ser
le va a volar baruta con la mueve el
seguro
se ve la bandera
el cocodrilo brindar shanghai en la
selva también a 9 mm hierro van a que me
dieron un buen sol y la nueva el pago
viene cuando se miran esfuerzo hay que
mover las bonitas al ritmo de la canción
para que se vayan apenas triste alegra
el corazón
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ahora
[Música]
el amor de militares a mover las bonitas
amores la bonita bonita y papel así
describe y vamos a volver la bonita
y dice así la nota si te paras casi 9
grados nunca siente para arriba un
pasito para arriba y ahora
[Música]
[Aplausos]
voy a ver a ver
para mover en la guarida si no la mueve
siempre va a poner baristas una buena
vez a mover la voluntad bueno la bbc
marisa en la vuelven las ballenas perder
mérito de mar una mujer maravilla al
bailar con superman
y ahora está gracias
también te voy a dar pena no se alegra
el corazón a ver a ver a mover las
bolitas
[Música]
sí no
estamos bien
a gobernador
bonita amores de gol y está la bolita
9na
[Aplausos]
[Música]
después también enamorado de la negra
tomasa que cuando se va a descansar
estoy enamorado de la tela cuando se va
de casa
césar
[Música]
en la realidad
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no no no
e
[Música]
y cuando se va de casa
[Aplausos]
[Música]
de esa manera
[Aplausos]
[Música]
está bien
[Aplausos]
[Música]
de la realidad
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no lo sé
más bella
[Música]
o no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
no
[Música]
i
vamos
[Música]
así
es una baja
[Aplausos]
[Música]